surprise okay I just want to spill
something Rebel Wilson is officially a
mom the actress shares the happy news on
Monday when she announced the birth of
her first child a baby girl via
surrogate the 42 year old who has been
candid about her fertility struggles in
the past shared this adorable first pick
of her newborn daughter on Instagram her
name Royce Lillian it's cool in the pig
baby Royce is covering her face in the
cutest pose rocking some unicorn socks
in a pale pink onesie Rebel captions a
photo quote I can't even describe the
love I have for her she's a beautiful
Miracle this has been years in the
making but particularly I want to thank
my gorgeous surrogate who carried her
and birthed her with such Grace and Care
thank you for helping me start my own
family it's an amazing gift the best
gift Rebel ends her announcement with a
promise to her daughter quote I am ready
to to give little roycie all the love
imaginable I am learning quickly much
respect to all the moms out there proud
to be in your Club that's right yeah as
for Rebels love life well she revealed
in June that she's dating fashion
designer Ramona arguma check out the
sweet snaps Ramona posted from Rebels
baby shower celebrating the mama to be
it's unclear if Ramona will co-parent
baby Royce with Rebel but there is one
thing we do know despite reports the
lovebirds are not engaged Aroma Rebel
debunked on her Instagram earlier this
month
I'm concentrating on health Rebels baby
announcement comes amid her ongoing
commitment to live her healthiest life
her priority improve her fertility and
opportunity to start a family the doctor
was like well you have a much better
chance of your healthier
and that like I was I was actually like
a bit offender because I thought even
though I'm bigger I thought I was pretty
healthy
um and and so that's kind of what
started that if I'd you know lost some
excess weight that it would give give me
a better chance for freezing eggs and
having the eggs be a better quality
um so that's what at first it wasn't
even really myself it was more thinking
of a future mini me really well it paid
off Rebel that future Mini Me is here
congratulations
[Music]